cédric hengbart est aujourd'hui un homme
ruiné dans les rues du centre-ville
d'auxerre l'ancien pro de la ga passe
presque inaperçue depuis des années ils
luttent pour ne pas sombrer tout ce que
j'ai gagné dans le football j'ai perdu
j'ai eu cette fille bien au total et qui
sont partis aujourd'hui et voilà j'ai pu
rien comment j'en suis arrivée là bas
par des placements financiers et
immobiliers concon pas été rentable et
un peu peut-être de laisser aline ma
part et puis pas mal de malveillance de
la part de certaines personnes
là gît à la ligue des champions les
salaires confortables
5 c'était la première vie de cédric
hengbart mais après des investissements
immobiliers qui ont viré au fiasco
l'ex footballeur a aujourd'hui près de 2
millions d'euros de dette
tous les biens ont été saisis il a dû
repartir de zéro samantha rendra sans
mon frère j'arrive à à vivre aujourd'hui
au quotidien grâce aussi à la famille de
mon ex compagne qui m'aide et qui
m'héberge par exemple donc donc voilà
j'ai beaucoup de gens autour de moi qui
mets dans cette situation là
comme lui plusieurs dizaines de
footballeurs professionnels ont été
victimes d'escroqueries une vaste
affaire qui met le promoteur immobilier
donc notaire ou avocat des gens que j'ai
apprécié énormément et qui ont abusé
peut-être de deux mois même de ma
confiance et mais bon au delà de ça ça
va aujourd'hui ça va aller à devant les
tribunaux et puis on verra ce qui se
passera par son témoignage cédric
hengbart espèrent bousculer un peu le
monde du football et que son expérience
met en garde les jeunes joueurs